okay today I'm going to teach you
something from c2 which is about
calculating masses in reactions what
this is all about is seeing how much of
a certain substance is required in order
to make another substance and we can you
do this using the periodic table and
some calculations so here's the kind of
question you might get what mass of
calcium reacts with oxygen to make 56
grams of calcium oxide so the first
thing to do is write a balanced symbol
equation now this will sometimes be
given for you but sometimes you might
have to do it yourself
okay but I'm not going to go too much
into that right now
so I've got calcium reacting with oxygen
to form calcium oxide is it balanced no
it's not again I'm not going to go too
much into balancing equations that's for
another another time so what the
question is saying is how much it
calcium do I need to make 56 grams of
this so eventually I want to see I want
to be able to make 56 grams of this I
need to know how much calcium would I
need to make 56 grams of this okay so
how do I go about this now the first
thing I need to do is I need to use my
periodic table to find the relative
atomic mass of calcium and the relative
formula mass of calcium oxide so let's
just quickly see so my relative atomic
mass of calcium is 40 so let's just get
that down here so it's 40 but I can see
I've got to lots of those calcium's so
it's going to be 40 times 2 which gives
me 80 now I'm not too interested about
the oxygen I'm only interested in the
calcium and the calcium oxide so I'm not
going to look in the oxygen for this
question what I'm then gonna do is I'm
going to do the same for this here so I
could see that again obviously my
calcium's relative atomic mass is 40 and
I've got two of these so four
calcium we've got 80 here and for oxygen
my relative atomic mass of oxygen is 60
again I've got two oxygens so that total
is 32 so in total my relative formula
mass of on this side of the equation of
my calcium oxide is 80 plus 32 which is
a hundred and twelve so let's have a
stop and have a think about what this
means these numbers of relative to each
other which means if we had 80 grams of
this we would make 112 grams of this it
also means if we had 80 tonnes of this
we would make a hundred and twelve tons
of this so they just show them relative
to each other how they relate to each
other so if I had 80 grams of this I
would make a hundred and twelve grams of
this however I'm not interested in
making 112 I'm interested in making 56
so the first thing I need to do is see
how much calcium would I need to make
just one gram of this so how do I do
that well I divide both by a hundred and
twelve divided by 112 so in my
calculator I'm going to do 80 divided by
112 Oh
it's given me quite a nasty number okay
I'm not going to worry about that right
now okay so I'm just going to show it at
the moment to two decimal places zero
point seven one so what I'm now saying
is 0.71 grams of this gives me one gram
of this but I'm not interested in making
one gram I'm interested in making 56
grams so what do I have to do well I
have the times both of these by 56
okay so we could see this one is now 56
grams so all I need to do is find my
answer is times this by 56 as well so
let's have a quick look notice how I
have left the answer in my calculator I
want that exact answer if I use this I
will get the wrong answer because I've
rounded it too early so if I now
multiply this by 56 there we go
we can see that my answer is 40 grams so
we could see I need 40 grams of calcium
to make 56 grams of calcium oxide so
that's how we do these remember the
order of events we've got to first of
all write a balanced equation what we've
then got to do is find the relative
relative formula mass of the different
things we're looking at then what we've
got to do is see how much of this we'd
need for just one gram by dividing by
the relative formula mass of the thing
that we were looking for then what we
need to do is multiply it by the mass
that will that we're looking for if you
follow these steps you should be alright
thank you very much